so I thought okay [__] it I'm gonna I'm
gonna ditch the the real job thing and
try out the whole YouTube thing and I
still remember to this day one year
after quitting my job looking at looking
at my YouTube channel and thinking oh
this is actually working it was such a
bizarre feeling and it still is kind of
bizarre now where I'm almost Jesus
almost eight years later
um so yeah basically it's a very slow uh
situation where a lot of luck was
involved but a lot of perseverance and
yeah that was pretty much it I went from
someone who had to give up wrestling
immediately there and then and I pretty
much didn't even watch wrestling after
that and I just focused entirely on
YouTube and Dragon Ball and Anime and
yeah the rest is history the rest of it
is documented on my channel so if you
want to check it out check it out